hebdo vie moderne à présent la
contraception quatre ans et demi après
le vote de la loi neuwirth à l'assemblée
nationale cette loi sur la contraception
commence à être appliquée vous savez que
les derniers décrets ont été publiés
récemment il concerne les règles de
formation et de fonctionnement des
organismes chargés de vous informer sur
cette question délicate d'intérêt
général hebdo vie moderne
annick beauchamp
paru au journal officiel il ya quelques
jours ça change quelque chose pour vous
madame je peux l'impression non mais je
le connais depuis longtemps chez sa vie
depuis longtemps donc je vois pas
tellement ce que ce que ça change
depuis l'apparition de ce quatrième
décret les français ont officiellement
droit à l'information concernant toutes
les méthodes contraceptives
mais ce décret ne définit pas clairement
les critères de formation de ceux qui
sont chargés d'informer le public
les mieux placés paraissent être les
collaborateurs du planning familial
parce qu'ils ont 11 ans d'expérience
pratique derrière nous sommes partis du
réel
nous avions des entretiens qui était une
chose réelle sur le vécu des gens et de
ce vécu nous sommes partis avec un
élargissement progressif et par
conséquent notre formation n'a rien
d'une information théorique est ce qu'on
vient vous voir ici uniquement pour des
problèmes d'ordre contraceptifs si au
début la formation contraceptifs
paraissait régler tous les problèmes on
s'est aperçus après que elle n'en règle
est que certains et que pour le reste
tout ce qui était informations ne
donnait pas immédiatement le
la relation bonne dans les couples
pouvaient rêver et que des résistances
apparaissait et que ces résistances il
fallait peu à peu les vaincre la plupart
des centres de planning familial ne sont
que des centres d'information
le planning voudrait que les consultants
de trouve sur place un médecin qui
prescrivent un moyen contraceptif
jusqu'à présent faute de moyens cette
politique n'a pu être appliqué qu'à
trois centres de la province
mais est ce que vous avez trouvé tout ce
que vous recherchez dans cette visite au
planning familial
oui j'ai eu toutes les informations
nécessaires mais je suis déçu parce que
je pensais voir un médecin et partie
repartir avec une ordonnance est
naturellement c'est gênant qu'on a deux
à chaque fois de redire ses problèmes de
foie si on peut avoir un médecin dans le
planning a alors c'est toujours facile
c'est pour faciliter les choses
sur les 300 centres du planning familial
existant en france il y en a trois
clermont ferrand toulouse i rouen
le premier en date qui soit le véritable
centre de contraception ça consiste en
quoi
centre de contraception c'est un centre
où il ya en même temps sur le même mieux
ensemble d'informations et un centre de
consultation médicale
je dois dire que cette démarche face aux
créations centre est important pour la
consultante qui vient parce qu'elle peut
dans le même temps faire un choix du
moyen de contraception et avant la
prescription qui permet d'utiliser ce
moyen de contraception
ça lui évite des déplacements salut est
venu du temps perdu et surtout ça la met
à l'aise par rapport au problème nous la
contraception elle n'est plus que tab
elysées et n'a plus de difficultés pour
ensuite l'employé ce moyen qu'elle a
choisi comment sait-il que roy et puis
ce seront les joueurs a pu créer ce
centre grâce à une subvention votée en
1968 par le conseil général
la seine-maritime et cette dimension
nous interdit d'avoir un poste de
permanent planning familial le poste est
ancrée et il ne restait plus qu'à créer
la structure et nous avions suffisamment
d'idées pour la mettre en place
quel est le portrait de votre adhérents
type vous en fais des statistiques
l'année dernière et nous avons eu la
joie de constater que le type de
l'adhérente de 1970 à rouen est
différent du type de la déroute de 1967
à paris
l'anc est de 67 10 aigles adhérentes i
petits merdeux une mère de famille de
deux enfants est institutrice nous à
rouen après avoir fait une animation une
sensibilisation générale le problème de
la sexualité la contraception
nous avons trouvé que l'adhérent type
était une mère de famille de quatre
enfants et femme d'ouvrier ce que vous
êtes des psychologues pour pouvoir
donner ce genre d'information et de
conseil non nous ne sommes pas des
psychologues
nous avons eu au départ une information
contraceptifs qui nous a permis donc ce
premier accueil contraceptive mais en
voyant les questions qui se posaient à
nous nous avons eu autour de nous un
certain nombre de personnes qui nous ont
apporté à la fois la théorie et les
les notions qui pouvait nous manque et
qui ressortent très souvent des sciences
humaines sociologie par exemple
psychologie bien sûr psychanalyse
également la loi malgré les demandes de
lucien neuwirth ne prévoit pas le
développement du planning familial et ne
lui accorde pas de subventions or si
l'on veut faire une bonne information
il faut de l'argent à l'heure actuelle
voici comment se présente vous allez le
voir la situation financière du planning
familial à paris vous êtes pauvres oui
le planning familial vie d'une part des
cotisations de ses adhérents et d'autre
part de certaines subventions soient des
subventions locales assez minime et il
avait eu de subventions plus importantes
de la caisse nationale des assurances
maladie et de la caisse nationale
d'allocations familiales
d'une part nous avons quelque sorte
réaliser nos objectifs c'est à dire
qu'on n'a pas seulement une information
sur la contraception quand on vient dans
des centres de planning
mais que de plus en plus nous nous
sommes insérés dans des services publics
que dans des hôpitaux dans des centres
de pmi dans des dispensaires et que donc
la service public
les gens qui viennent en consultation ne
vois pas pourquoi il brille une
cotisation à une association privée et
ça c'est un des aspects dali mission de
nos adhésions et d'autre part nous
sommes aussi de plus en plus demandés
pour un travail éducatif que ce soit
dans les établissements scolaires auprès
d'écoles d'infirmières dessine social
dans des comités d'entreprise dans
différentes organismes associations et
au fond les prestations éducatives que
se prennent difficilement change
il reste beaucoup à faire notamment en
milieu rural et ouvriers parmi ceux ci
on ne parle guère du planning familial
et de la formation contraceptive ces
sujets sont jugés trop intime et
pourtant il faudrait que là aussi des
couples aient droit à l'information et
que la contraception libère les femmes
et donc les foyers